I constantly cannot verbalize my
thoughts,
written and focal regardless of topic
and my level of knowledge.
Tips for verbalizing,
thoughts to get them into writing and
therefore speech.
Well,
what I would say Lauren is do this like
read something,
put a decide,
try to summarize it in writing and talk
while you're doing it.
And then write down what you say and
don't edit while you're doing that.
See what are the problems that people
have when they're trying to write is
they try to write a good sentence.
They not only tried to write a sentence,
but they try to write a good sentence
and you can't do that.
You have to write a sentence that's hard
enough and then you have to edit it.
So allow yourself to write badly.
I'm dead serious about this.
Like write a bad,
bad,
bad first draft and then edit it if you
get rid of 70% of it.
So what?
That's exactly what should happen.
So like if you want to write a thousand
word essay,
you should start by writing a really bad
2000 word essay and then you should get
rid of the worst 50% you can do that
iteratively.
I have a document online.
It's,
it's,
if you go to my website,
under courses,
there's psychology for 30 is the course.
I should make this more public.
But under cycle psychology for 30,
there's a template for writing.
And if you went and looked at that
template,
it tells you it answers your question.
I,
I produced this little guide book for,
for writing that will help.
And if you write enough,
you'll learn to speak.
The other thing I would say too is that
it might be anxiety that's doing,
you might think about joining a club
like toastmasters or maybe if you're a
university student to public speaking,
uh,
something where you'd get in front of
people.
And then when you're in front of people,
don't talk to the group,
talked to the individuals within the
group and let yourself be bad at it.
You'll get better as you practice.